General John J Pershing arrives in France to
command the two and a half million men in the
American Expeditionary Force Lafayette here they
come burns detachment of America's door boys
disembarked somewhere in France as America
moves to make the world safe for democracy
actual shots of fishings been taken on the field
of action this was the army pressing bill from
hundreds of thousands of raw recruits carrying
out the daring doctrine of open warfare which
was the American strategy mobile units which
vindicated Pershing's judgment by smashing
the German Syria to the Samba shelf in September
1917 met with tremendous objection from British
French leaders but they were to eventually pass
the enemy out of the Argonne driving forward to
almost impossible terrain first careers a leader
of men began when he address point of putting
master of troop formations an artillery barrage
20 his first love of the cavalry at Amazon for
back then he fought the Apache in Dakota Indians
but this war is different the big guns were seeing
now armed enemy opposition with pressing right
with them at the front and inspiration to his bed
as American troops recaptured French town after
town freshening Zara triumph is near
for the German army was getting up
then came to member 1918 and the armistice in
France pressing greet President Wilson greatest
for the generals previous glories Marie such
as the Philippines where Theodore was about
honored his accomplishments by raising his rank
from captain to Brigadier General Don eclipsed
this greatest of all his personal triumphs
however the Armistice for which port was the
one disappointment of World War one to him for
a 1941 when he offered his services after Pearl
Harbor he declared if we had gone on to Berlin
in 1918 we would not be going back now but back
to Paris but Pershing leading to victory parade
just prior to returning to accept America's homage
it's September 1919 as the Leviathan comes to the
New York Harbor and general pressing on board is
given a tremendous ovation the war is over at a
city pays homage to the man who led to victory
Congress is to confer on him uh
supreme honor after this reception
by Al Smith and Mayor John air pilot
get us to make him buy special acts
General of the armies only man since
George Washington to bear that title
here Washington DC duplicates New York's
perception for the general on his favorite
black horse leading a parade down Pennsylvania
Avenue and then 29 years later July 15 1948
threshing is dead the capital of the nation for
which he fought so valiantly now seize him born to
a last resting place tracing retired in 1924 after
making thousands of friends and all walks of life
down Pennsylvania Avenue comes
this sorrowful possession
General Omar Bradley along with
Legionnaire representatives mourns
as the last benediction is read
and the mortal remains of a hero
are about to be entrusted to the earth
in Arlington Cemetery a spot he himself
shows John J Pershing is gone but America's
freedom is a lasting eulogy to his memory